vous avez un problème avec le charger
votre smartphone et vous vous demandez
quel chargeur prendre quel chargeur
achetez vous avez trouvé un vieux charge
dans vos tiroirs et vous demander si
fera l'achat pour venir charger votre
smartphone parce que vous avez perdu
parce que votre chargeur est abîmée ne
fonctionne plus alors dans cette vidéo
je vais vous aider à dégrossir tout ça
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
complexe au sujet qui n'est pas
forcément évident pour savoir quel
chargeur venir utiliser parce que si
vous utilisez un chargeur de mauvaise
qualité vous avez les risques avec le
feu chez vous rassurez vous on va pas
mettre le feu comme ça à la maison mais
il faut vraiment faire attention il faut
se dire comprendre quelle est la
différence entre les différents charger
pour au final acheter le chargeur qu'il
vous faut qui vous correspond pour niro
charger votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai il faut pas acheter n'importe
quoi parce que ce avec deux chargeurs
on avait des tonnes entre les gros
chargeurs des chargeurs petit des
chargeurs différents de télécharger un
moyen de tous enfin il existe des tonnes
de type de chargeur et savoir lequel
utiliser c'est pas toujours évident et
encore plus lorsque vous allez sur
internet vous regardez ce que se charge
en effet pour mon téléphone c'est pas
évident et je vous comprends parce que
franchement c'est la gagne j'ai pas vous
faire une liste complète pour vous dire
qu'elle chargeait à venir acheter pour
les téléphones parce qu'on a tellement
ça serait très compliqué ce que j'ai
fait tout de suite dès maintenant je les
fais une liste en bas dans la
description aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil comme ça je vais vous mettre
enfin de certains modèles des chargeurs
en tout cas les plus courants et je vous
mets plein de liens en bas pour venir
vous aider pour vous guider parce que
c'est pas très évident et j'en ai
vraiment conscience que je vais essayer
de vous aider et la toute première chose
et bien c'est d'essayer de comprendre
déjà comment fonctionnent ces chargeurs
parce que d'un chargeur 65 watts à un
chargeur 5 watts il ya une vraie
différence une vraie différence que
significative il voulait pas pouvoir
dire utilisez votre chargeur 65 watts
pour recharger n'importe quel téléphone
sans risquer d'endommager la batterie
nouveau smartphone donc ça pourrait être
aussi relativement dommage alors la
toute première chose on va se reprendre
des notions un petit peu simple qu'il
faut venir comprendre ici très souvent
les constructeurs vous parle de
puissance de charge la puissance de
charge
elle est donnée en watts donc vous avez
des chargeurs 15 wade charger 18 watts
25 x 33 watts 65 ans peut même monter
jusqu'à 100 watts maintenant c'est dire
et en fait c'est puissance en watts elle
vient pas de n'importe où elle vient de
deux choses
elle vient de votre tension tension
électrique qui elle s'exprime en volt
qu'on va retrouver avec un v voilà comme
ça on fait un peu les comptes physique
on revient un peu dans la physique
et puis vous avez d'un autre côté ce
qu'on va appeler l' intensité face et
l'intensité du courant qui s'exprime en
en perd et qu'on notera avec hara et le
couple tension intensité vaudra votre
puissance
autant dire les volts et les ans perdent
deux robots watts et pas en souffrance
se charger d'iphone alors un peu old
school parce qu'aujourd'hui ça ressemble
plus à sac à ça ici par exemple eh bien
voyez j'ai un chargeur avec 5 volts et
une en perd et si c'est tout bête en
fait pour comprendre il suffit de faire
une multiplication cinq fois zain et ben
ça va donner un chargeur 5 watts
a contrario je vais prendre celui là là
que j'ai pour mon iphone 12 pronax ici
par contre je vais avoir neuf
holt deux ans père est ici forcément je
multiplie ici j'ai donc un chargeur 18
watts la même chose je vais vous prendre
par exemple le monde au pot ici c'est la
superbe look 2.0 gdi volts j'ai 6,5 en
perd ça me fait donc un chargeur 65
watts enfin vous avez compris l'histoire
donc ça c'est vraiment toi qu'il faut
venir voir à l'arrière de son chargeur
ce site vous en prendre à où c'est écrit
un petit peu gros il est marqué une
poutre l'input ça correspond au courant
qu'ils rentrent depuis votre prise
électrique jusque dans votre chargeur et
sans votera aux poudres c'est pas très
évident à lire vous allez être a dit
volts et 6,5 en perd donc votre 65 watts
maximum que vous allez retrouver ici là
ont des chiots en plus il faut vraiment
bien différente et ses deux points entre
d'un côté la tension volts et l'autre
côté l'intensité en empêche si on peut
faire une comparaison on va retourner
toujours un petit peu plus dans l'est
l'idée de la physique comme on l'avait
ricol vous vous imaginez vous avez une
pile avec d'un côté votre plus de côté
votre - et vous avez un circuit
électrique avec d'un autre côté ici une
ampoule or je sais je dessine pas très
bien mais si c'est une ampoule votre
courant ça vient là et ça vous allumez
votre ampoule vous ai compris un peu
l'histoire ça circule du plus vers le
moins l'attention qui s'exprime en volt
en fait ça avec la vitesse de
déplacement
il savait que tout le plus important
pour votre charge si vous le comparez au
courant d'une rivière plus vous allez
avoir de volts et plus vous avez avoir
une eau qui va être déchaîné qui va
avancer super vite et moi vous allez à
bord de vols et plus on va avancer
doucement donc imaginer que si vous en
voyez beaucoup de vols dans un
smartphone qui n'acceptent pas beaucoup
de volts et bien vous risquez vraiment
devenir endommagé ici la batterie du
smartphone et les ampère l'intensité que
vous avez mesuré à un instant t par
exemple lucie hop là vous allez mettre
maintenant permettre et vous allez venir
mesurer si l'intensité du courant mais
ça va correspondre à la quantité d'eau
qui se déplace toujours pour avoir cette
analogie là ça veut dire que si on vient
comparez vous imaginé d'abord un gros
débit de donc là vous allez voir
beaucoup de volts et vous pouvez avoir
une petite quantité qui se déplacent ça
par analogie ça va correspondre aux en
perd donc les enfers c'est pas très très
grave ce n'est pas tout car nous embêter
le plus ce qui est plus important c'est
d'avoir les voltes correspondent à ce
que votre smartphone peut encaisser
parce que si vous regardez ici je vois
qu'ici je suis sur un iphone d'ancienne
génération ça c'est un vieux 1
et bien c'est du cinquante si je vais au
delà de 5 watts ça va pas le faire ici a
contrario je suis sur un iphone 12 par
exemple iphone 12 iphone 12 pro max et
compagnie mais 9 volts il les encaisse
sans aucun problème ici je suis chez au
pot sur 1
find x3 pro donc là je vois que j'ai dit
volts ça va être la même chose pour un
one + 9 pro mais si je regarde par
exemple sur un google je suis sur un
pixel 5
ben là je me retrouve avec 5 volts 2 ans
perd non pas 5 volts neuf vols voilà je
vous dis n'importe quoi ces neuf vols
deux en perse et de la recharge 18 watts
il faut donc venir faire match est
réellement votre smartphone avec le
chargeur alors la première solution à ce
que j'aimerais moi réellement vous
conseillez derrière c'est d'aller
acheter un chargeur sur le site du
fabricant comme ça au moins vous êtes
tranquille vous savez que vous avez les
chargeurs qui correspond optimisé par le
fabricant vous êtes pena je vais par
exemple sur le site d'apple
je vois qu'ici j'ai un adaptateur
secteur usb c'est 20 watts
je suis à 25 euros donc le mieux ici si
vous avez un iphone et bien c'est
devenir l'acheter directement ici comme
ça moi vous n'avez pas de problème n'est
pas de mauvaise surprise
de la même manière si vous allez j'en
sais rien par exemple chez samsung vous
avez différents charger vous avez de la
recharge ultra rapide 25 watts avec ou
sans câble on voit qu'on a quand même
une différence de 10 euros par cas parce
que oui bien évidemment aussi il ya un
techno qui est importante à venir
regarder au niveau du câble parce que
les cavs vont pas pouvoir venir encaissé
la même puissance
et si vous trouvez pas votre bonheur sur
le site du constructeur et bien ce que
je vous invite réellement à venir faire
c'est vous prenez votre blog de charges
il faut caler derrière ce qui est marqué
au niveau de la haute route pour garder
votre couple tension intensité les volts
et les amp est en fait la multiplication
et vous obtenez dans votre puissance en
watts et vous voyez donc ce que vous
pouvez venir mettre en puissance en
watts
il ya plein de marques qui vous propose
des chargeurs extrêmement sérieux vous
serez tranquille vous serez rassurés je
peux pas tous vous les énumérer une fois
de plus parce qu'il y en aurait quand
même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup je vous
ai mis à des liens en bas dans la
description alister coup d'oeil pour
trouver le chargeur qui peut
correspondre en tout cas votre
smartphone a tout fait cette vidéo
aujourd'hui on est en avril 2021 je
connais les smartphones qui sont sortis
je ne connais pas ce qu'ils vont arriver
donc je ne peux pas avoir toutes les
données par rapport au modèle que vous
allez acheter à l'instant t où vous
allez regarder cette vidéo melide
et là vous avez compris donc je vous
mets des liens aller jeter un coup
d'oeil vers des sites qui sont vraiment
sérieux avec lesquels vous saurez que
vous n'aurez absolument aucun problème
parce que ce qui est super important
c'est pas vous laisser avoir par le prix
dans le monde des fabricants de charger
il ya de tout il ya à boire et à manger
vous avez des gens très sérieux et vous
en avez d'autres qui vont proposer des
tarifs extrêmement bas sur différentes
marketplace qui vont vous appâter au
niveau du prix mais avec des finitions
de fabrication qui vont pas être à la
hauteur
et là vous allez avoir des risques d'une
d'endommager la batterie de votre
smartphone ce qui veut dire et dans ce
cas là avec le moins pire le risque le
moins élevés et le risque plus élevé et
bien c'est de mettre le feu chez vous
c'est pas dès que ça va forcément
arriver mais je vous conseille vraiment
mais vraiment vraiment vraiment de venir
acheter chez des gens sérieux
je vous ai mis des rien une fois de plus
dans la description pour au moins ne pas
prendre des risques
lorsque vous allez venir acheter le
nouveau chargeur de votre smartphone
chaque fabricant sa technologie de
charge on le voit notamment avec eux au
pot on va voir la voûte de la superbe
look on le voit avec one pluzz on va
avoir de la varde charge chaque
fabricant à son nom sont emig sa marque
pour sa recharge rapide parce que
aujourd'hui effectivement ce que les
marques veulent mettre en avant ses de
la recharge rapide il ya deux standards
qui se sont détachés la toute première
c'est la couette charge de qualcomm qui
adapté pour les processeurs snapdragon
je voulais un lien également bas dans la
description l'extérieur parce que c'est
intéressant
c'est un document de qualcomm alors il
est en anglais mais on comprend très
très bien vous inquiétez pas vous verrez
les différentes générations de coups de
charge et vous verrez la liste des
smartphones qui acceptent cette kutxa et
puis vous en avez un autre c'est le
power des livres i en usb sierre savait
pas ya parce que votre charge dans l'usb
6 et forcément du power des livres i
mais c'est un hub standard donc on a
vraiment ces deux grands standards à
garder en tête
regardez vous votre modèle quelle
technologie de charge il a épuisé bien
évidemment la question de la connectique
on avait beaucoup de câbles en micro usb
qui disparaissent de plus en plus le
standard c'est l'usbc mais si vous allez
chez apple par exemple vous êtes sûre du
lightning à main au gousset sur des ipad
pro auquel cas vous êtes sur usb c'est
donc en fait un chargeur s'est pas
uniquement l'adaptateur secteur charger
c'est en l'adaptateur secteur plus un
câble et surtout vérifier que
l'adaptateur secteur qui vous est vendu
que le chargeur qui vous est vendu à
bien toutes les normes européennes et
que c'est pas un produit qui vient de
jeunes saison sans normes auquel cas là
il faut passer son chemin
donc si on récapitule c'est très simple
on prend son chargeur actuelle on
regarde on peut venir encaissé en termes
d'eau
at on regarde les voltes les ans perd
c'est pas très grave il faut vraiment
que les vols correspondent et là dessus
vous serez tranquille donc regarder ce
qu'il en est et puis surtout un dernier
conseil extrêmement important je vous en
ai déjà parlé dans une précédente vidéo
concernant la charge de votre smartphone
mieux vous charger un smartphone plutôt
lentement sa préservera la durée de vie
de votre batterie dans le temps j'espère
vous aurez idée ne sais pas me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas aux
commentaires et une fois de plus pour
vous guider davantage sauvegardées via
les liens que vous aimez en bas dans la
description pour trouver le chargeur qui
correspond au modèle que vous avez sur
ce je vous embrasse son à beaucoup
d'amour pour les soins nouveau lieu très
vite ciao